I've experienced like certain traumas
like as I've gotten older right and I've
noticed that my body like because your
muscles store this trauma and I've
noticed that my body can go into
the trauma right if I'm if I'm triggered
by something whatever it may be and so
for me I'm like oh like I need to
work on this to figure out how to get
through this and pass this trauma so I
literally don't physically react like
I'll I won't be able to like eat and
I'll be like hunched over and I'll be
like in pain like nauseous I'm like why
can't I just talk myself out of this and
I really do believe that it is because
your muscles store this memory
and so your memory is like the trauma
thing oh it's connected to everything
right right yeah and so and it might not
have anything to do with what the trauma
was about but it's it's
probably has something to do with what
the trauma is about but and it just
brings that out and that's the hardest
thing and so